can't beans properly home-cooked popcorn
start off with just a touch of oil in
there as it lightly starts to smoke corn
in so now get your lid
never leave it far away from me sounds
like it's raining it's not those popcorn
kernels to pop out a little shake of the
pan get it going and then lift that lid
at your peril we see a very excited pan
in there and we're all that little
pitter-patter stops you know your
popcorn is cooked nice you could eat it
fresh from the pan but I've got another
plan I'm gonna make a salted caramel
popcorn start off with your sugar into
that pan never stir a caramel otherwise
it crystallizes it's a salted caramel so
a nice pinch of salt in there as well
now once you've got it to a really nice
dark caramel flavor stir in your butter
very carefully
camels very very hot half a teaspoon of
bicarbonate of soda kick starts to the
reaction that gives the caramel a
honeycomb flavor mix that in you'll see
it reacting almost like a large crunchy
in the bottom of your bowl
now the gas is off and that camera the
nice dark rich flavor now pouring the
popcorn to coat it with that incredible
caramel give that a good mix it's that
easy and it's gonna taste amazing lay
that nice and flat once that cools down
it becomes nice and brittle we got that
nice salted caramel flavor which just
takes popcorn to compete in level